des algériens en colère une opposition
qui n'a pas hésité à monter au créneau
ces derniers jours l'algérie est en
proie à d'importants feux de forêt est
déclarée dans le nord du pays en haute
kabylie les oulaya de tizi ouzou et
béjaïa pleurent leurs morts parmi les
victimes des militaires et des civils
alors que des foyers demeurent toujours
incontrôlables face à la situation
beaucoup d'habitants déplorent le manque
de réactivité du gouvernement écouter
les soldats et les membres de la garde
nationale se sont rendus sur le terrain
pour aider est un incendie mais les
fonctionnaires haut placés n'ont vu
aucun d'entre eux et ils ne les ont pas
cherché je n'ai de problème avec
personne mais vous voyez de vos propres
yeux des crimes contre l'humanité c'est
vraiment une catastrophe plus tôt la
pire des catastrophes
qualité et choix tout comme les civils
l'opposition elle aussi est monté au
créneau c'est le cas du rassemblement
pour la culture et la démocratie qui
s'en est violemment pris au gouvernement
dans un communiqué rendu public hier
leur chef de file mohcine belabbas a
déploré un manque flagrant de moyens de
lutte contre les feux de forêt appelant
les autorités à se doter d'un nombre
important de canadair elle la totale
absence de réactivité et d'anticipation
une communication des plus archaïques
sont caractéristiques de la gestion de
cette présente crise qui dure à l'ère
des télécommunications de pointe et des
technologies ultramodernes de
l'information et de la communication le
chef de l'état est incapable de
s'adresser au peuple par l'image et le
son dans ces moments de désarroi de
deuil et de tristesse
le reste du gouvernement n'est pas en
reste de leur côté le ministre de
l'intérieur et le premier ministre ont
affirmé hier que les incendies qui ont
touché la wilaya de tizi ouzou sont
d'origine criminelle évoquant un acte
prémédité pour faire le plus de dégâts
l'état comme vous pouvez le constater
déploie tous ses efforts et nous avons
utilisé toutes les possibilités et les
équipements publics pour accueillir les
citoyens qui ont été touchés par cette
catastrophe nous avons donné des
instructions strictes aux gouverneurs
des régions pour qu'ils ordonnent à tous
les logements universitaires
actuellement disponibles et à tous les
hôtels même privé d'accueillir tous les
citoyennes qui ont été touchés par ces
incendies et de leur fournir tous les
moyens
sert pour un logement décent de la
meilleure façon jusqu'à ce que cette
catastrophe parce si dieu le veut un
gouvernement visé par la grogne
populaire déjà dépassés par la situation
sanitaire avec une explosion des cas
depuis début juillet et un manque de
moyens pour y faire face le pouvoir à
alger est à nouveau la cible des réseaux
sociaux qui dénonce les défaillances de
l'état